one of my favorite songs of all time
which i was shocked that you covered was
warren zevon's keep me in your heart
i remember seeing warren zivan on
letterman
and warren's ivan knew he was dying it
was the saddest thing
david letterman kept the whole hour
dedicated to warren zebon
do you know something about life and
death that maybe i don't know
no
not unless i know how much how much
you're supposed to enjoy every sandwich
i couldn't even watch it it was so sad
he writes this gut-wrenching song i know
i'm dying
and i want you guys to remember me when
i'm gone just keep me in your heart
somewhere
and you do a cover of that i did it for
for dave
yeah they've got the mark twain award in
dc
i know you have a guitar there would you
be in the mood to play that song
sure i'll always play that all right
[Music]
shadows are falling and i'm running out
of breath
keep me in your heart for a while
if i leave here it doesn't mean i
love you any less keep me in your heart
for a
while when you get up in the morning and
you
see that crazy sun keep me in your [ __ ]
for a while there's a train leaving
nightly
[Music]
keep me in your heart for a while
[Music]
keep me in your heart for a while
sometimes when you're doing simple
things around the house
maybe you'll think of me and smile
[Music]
if you know i'm tied to you
like the buttons on your blouse
keep me in your heart for a while
hold me in your thoughts take me
your dreams trust me when i fall
[Music]
right next to you
the engine drivers heading north the
pleasant stream
keep me in your heart for a while
you know these wheels they keep turning
but they're running out of steam keep me
in your heart for a while
[Music]
keep me in your heart for a while
keep me in your heart free while
keep me in your heart
[Applause]
beautiful god i love that song
what an emotional song probably his best
song ever right
yeah he wrote so many good ones and and
all
great stories but yeah that one uh yeah
that's hard to come by